there are monsters out there lurking in
the
dark for centuries astronomers scanned
the heavens again and again without ever
spying them but behind the familiar
stars and nearby calm galaxies of our
universe lay something far more vicious
far more terrible and far more
powerful completely invisible to the
human eye you would never see them even
on the darkest of nights indeed at first
they appeared as nothing but dim distant
pin Pricks of strange radio emission but
those pin Pricks revealed something no
astronomer could ever have expected
something so strange so bizarre that for
years nobody even believed that they
could exist that there must have been
some mistake in our
observations thankfully none are nearby
for if they were any closer they would
flood us our galaxy our solar system our
planet with deadly radiation a single
one of these monsters can easily pump
out over 10 to the power of 40 Jews
every second for comparison our sun
outputs about 10 to the power of 34 Jews
a million times less every year the
brightest among them outshine Stars
outshine galaxies outshine a thousand
galaxies at once some extreme events
like the most powerful Supernova can
briefly become brighter than these
beacons but those events are temporary
ephemeral flaring and dimming in a
matter of weeks when these monsters
awaken they stay powered for millions of
years in just a fraction of their
lifetime they can easily produce more
energy than even the most intense Cosmic
explosions and they are
hungry they feed on anything and are
capable of tearing apart entire stars in
a single fit of rage producing flashes
of radiation and jets of charged
particles that shoot out for millions of
light years piercing through galaxies
and spreading their destruction
throughout entire
clusters they are the quazars the most
powerful engines in the known
universe but what drives these engines
what powers these lighthouses in the
Deep the answer will take us on a
journey through some of the most extreme
physics in the universe and even provide
us with a grim warning for though our
galaxy is quiet now it will not stay
that way
[Music]
forever the most distant quazar from us
is 13 billion light years away it would
take nearly the entire history of the
universe to travel to and that's without
the universe expanding at the same time
space is big and getting bigger and
sometimes that can make us feel small
better help is our sponsor today they
are the world's largest therapy service
under 100% online better help can match
you to one of over 30,000 therapists in
their network based on your needs
preferences and location giving you
access to a wider range of expertise
than may be available in your area of
the universe you can schedule therapy
sessions at a time that's convenient for
you and if you feel like your therapist
isn't a great fit you can switch
therapists with a click of a button in
your settings at no additional cost with
better help you get the same
professionalism and quality you expect
from in-office therapy but with a
therapist who is custom picked for you
with more scheduling flexibility and at
a more affordable price so get 10% off
your first month at betterhelp.com
[Music]
hotu and I've also linked them Below in
the description thanks to better help
for supporting educational content on
YouTube
at first astronomers had no idea what
they were
seeing by the 1950s science had grown
used to the idea of galaxies outside the
Milky Way But even in this expanded
cosmological view the belief was that
the Universe was relatively small only a
few billion light years across at most
and that expanded Cosmos seemed
relatively simple even boring there were
galaxies there were clusters of galaxies
there were vast expanses of nothingness
for a Time astronomers were able to
convince themselves that they were
finally starting to figure things out
but in the mid 20th century there was a
technological Revolution optical
telescopes capable of seeing objects inv
visible wavelengths of light were
becoming enormous and our ability to use
the rest of the electromagnetic spectrum
wavelengths of light outside the visible
grew along with that and with with these
new observations came the realization
that the Universe was Far weirder than
we could have ever
imagined one of the first revolutions
was in radio in the 1930s the pioneering
engineer Carl jansky solved the problem
of how to reduce noise in sensitive
radio antenna and discovered the first
radio signals coming from deep space
among many bright and obvious sources
like Jupiter The Crab Nebula and nearby
galaxies astronomers also discovered
numerous small faint distant pointlike
radio
objects these strange objects appeared
all over the sky emitted radio waves at
a broad range of wavelengths and could
not be seen with visible or infrared
telescopes the only clue they gave was
their position they appeared both within
the band of the Milky Way and outside of
it since our galaxy is a thin disc this
meant that the sources either had to be
extremely close like the visible stars
of the night sky or extremely far away
like the distant galaxies but if they
were close we should have been able to
see them in Optical wavelengths and if
they were extremely far away their
intensity in radio wavelengths implied
they were the brightest objects in the
entire
universe
understandably many astronomers pushed
back against this interpretation not
only arguing about their distance but
also openly questioning what could
possibly power something that bright
finally a breakthrough came in
1962 by the 1960s astronomers had been
able to refine the techniques of radio
astronomy to the point they could more
precisely measure the location on the
sky of these strange sources with these
new techniques astronomer seral Hazard
and John Bolton found that one radio
Source known as 3c273 would undergo
occultations of the Moon allowing them
to provide an extremely accurate
estimate of its position following up on
that work the Dutch American astronomer
Martin Schmid discovered a faint object
in the same location in the visible
spectrum within that visible light
Schmidt found a usual collection of
bright spectral lines and dark gaps the
Fingerprints of elements and molecules
found throughout the cosmos but these
lines were not in their usual
wavelengths instead they were shifted
towards the red end of the Spectrum by
nearly
16% to get that kind of red shifting
either 3c273 had to be moving away from
us at an incredibly fast speed or it had
to be incredibly far away by this time
astronomers had been slowly accepting
The Big Bang Theory of the universe The
View that the cosmos was once smaller in
the past and is continuing to grow in
the present day under cosmological
expansion light from distant objects red
shifts because the space between them
and US expands stretching the light out
into longer wavelengths and when he
interpreted the red shifting of the
light from 3c273
Schmidt realized it sat 3.4 billion
light years away it was the most distant
object by an order of magnitude ever
observed
in 1966 Time Magazine put Martin Schmidt
on its cover comparing the magnitude of
his Discovery to those of Galileo saying
the 17th century Italian startled
scientists and theologians alike the
20th century Dutchman has had an equally
jarring effect on his own
contemporaries 3c273 was a revelation it
is so distant that it appears to us a
simp simply a point-like object of
incredible luminosity in fact making it
another recordbreaker it was also the
brightest known object in astronomy at
the time stranger still 3c273 was
remarkably compact now knowing the
location of the object astronomers dug
back through archival photographic
plates and found that earlier
generations of astronomers had already
seen it without recognizing it for what
it was year after year 3c273 had shown
up but its brightness had varied between
annual observations to change brightness
within a year an object must be smaller
than a light year across because any
changes to the object can only propagate
at a speed lower than the speed of light
So Not only was 3c273 Far brighter and
far more distant than any known object
it managed to accomplish both these
Feats in a volume smaller than our solar
system with this technique of M Ming
radio sources to visible light objects
in place astronomers went on to confirm
the distances to dozens of these
so-called quasi Stell radio sources the
name coming about as early astronomers
knew that these objects were not normal
stars but had absolutely no clue what
they actually could be it was in 1964
that the astrophysicist Hong Yi Chu
coined its modern catchier name in the
journal physics
today so far the clumsily long name
quasi Stellar radio sources is used to
describe these objects for convenience
the abbreviated form quaza will be used
throughout this
paper and so the quazar was
born debate over the true nature of
quazars raged for decades within the
astronomical Community many astronomers
believe that the original interpretation
was correct that these were incredibly
bright incredibly Compact and Incredibly
distant objects but they could not
explain what powered these extreme
objects others continued to argue that
these were some sort of exotic star much
closer to our own Galaxy that provided
such an extreme amount of gravitational
pull the light escaping from them would
red shift making them appear much more
distant than they really were but it
wasn't one decisive measurement that
cemented the cosmological nature of
quazar but rather a gradual buildup of
observational pressure which grew handin
hand with the acceptance of the Big
Bang The Big Bang Theory tells us that
the Universe changes with time Not only
was it smaller in the past it was also
different quazars only appear in the
extremely distant Universe indeed the
nearest quazar sits over 700 million Li
years away since astronomy acts like a
time machine with more distant
observations revealing the nature of a
younger Universe these observations tell
us that quazars were only active in the
distant pass and have now gone quiet
this idea fits perfectly with the big
bang because we expect the universe to
change as it evolves with time our
Dawning understanding of the age and
size of the universe helped paint a
portrit of a gigantic ancient Cosmos
that could easily accommodate the
distances to even the most farflung
quaza and so astronomers were left with
little choice they had to accept that
these strange intense objects were truly
far away and truly bizarrely
[Music]
bright as news of the discovery of
quazars worked its way from purely
astronomical circles and into the
popular imagination public interest
skyrocketed with writers using the term
to elicit a sense of strangeness and
remoteness and if you need a new nursery
rhyme to soothe your child you can take
the words of legendary physicist George
gamov twinkle twinkle quasi star biggest
puzzle from afar how unlike the other
ones brighter than a billion Suns
twinkle twinkle quasi star how I wonder
what you
are meanwhile astronomers discovered
more and more quazars including ones
that were both unusually bright and
oddly dim the very brightest ones got a
new name blazar While others weren't
emitting any radio waves at all but Were
Somehow extremely bright in x-ray
radiation and as radio astronomy became
more sophisticated astronomers were able
to capture smaller finer details the
most famous example was signus a one of
the brightest radio objects in the
entire Sky initially thought to be an
exotic Radio Star when it was was first
discovered by the 1950s astronomers
realized it was far stranger the central
core of signus a was a Galaxy but
extending hundreds of thousands of Li
years away from that core with two Thin
long Jets ending in gigantic bubbles
screaming in radio
emission all of these strange objects
whether loud or quiet in the radio
whether relatively nearby or extremely
distant shared one thing in common their
cause were abnormally
bright in some cases the nuclei of the
galaxies outshone all the hundreds of
billions of stars within the galaxies
themselves the brightest of these cores
indicated an enormous amount of activity
of Unknown Origin without knowing the
true explanation astronomers conceived
of a brand new term to Encompass them
all active Galactic
nuclei and so what was going on in the
cores of these galaxies why were some
the most luminous objects in the
universe While others were relatively
quiet what generated the radio emissions
and why did some blast out x-ray
radiation astronomers had discovered a
zoo of active galaxies throughout the
cosmos with a dizzying and confusing
array of Galactic
creatures something must power them
something must generate the energies
needed to make the brightest of them
outshine a thousand galaxies at once
something must enable them to be seen
from the distant reaches of the far
Universe these active Galactic nuclei
must have something in common and it was
clear that that something lived in their
cause and so to understand what drives
these the most powerful engines in the
known
universe we have to look a little closer
to
home
25,000 light years away sits a
monster we wouldn't know it by looking
at it we can't see this monster with our
own eyes we can't see it with telescopes
but even decades ago we knew that
something strange was there when we look
out at the sky on a dark clear night we
can see the band of the Milky Way the
Milky Way is brightest in the direction
of the constellation Sagittarius and
it's there that astronomers discovered
the core of our galaxy and when radio
astronomers began their first hesitant
explorations of the sky they also found
a bright source of radio emission coming
from this point later astronomers
building a catalog of radio sources
ranked the brightest object in each
constellation in alphabetical order and
so the bright Source in Sagittarius
became known as Sagittarius
A still later more detailed observations
revealed an exceptionally bright
point-like object buried within the
larger Sagittarius a complex because the
discovery was exciting and excited
States and atoms get labeled with an
asterisk the modern name for the object
at the very center of the Milky Way was
born Sagittarius A star it was the same
problem posed by the distant quazars but
much closer to home what could possibly
power the bright radio emissions coming
from the center of our galaxy and so
they pushed deeper into the Maelstrom
and deep within the core of Sagittarius
A star astronomers found Stars pin
Pricks of light dancing and swirling
repeated observations showed that the
stars were orbiting around some unseen
companion Bound by chains of gravity to
something massive and something dark
simple calculations of orbital mechanics
revealed the mass mass of the central
object forcing scientists to acknowledge
the existence of an entity weighing over
4 million solar
masses debates swirled for decades but
eventually only one plausible answer
remained Sagittarius A star was a super
massive black
[Music]
hole black holes are common throughout
the Universe most the leftover remnant
of a massive star these black holes are
usually relatively small weighing only a
few times the mass of the Sun but the
mysterious object at the center of our
galaxy weighed millions of times the
mass how could such a giant black hole
form and how could it find itself at the
center of our
galaxy in 2022 all debate on its
identity was put to rest when the Event
Horizon telescope unveiled their
stunning image of of Sagittarius AAR
using a network of telescopes spanning
the entire Globe The Event Horizon
telescope team spent years carefully
combining and correlating their data the
result was a blurry low-resolution image
of the true nightmare sitting within our
Galaxy's heart a fuzzy ring of
superheated plasma swirls around an
evacuated core of pure Blackness at the
very center lies the black hole itself
its Event Horizon preventing any
background light from traveling through
it with the immense mass of the super
massive black hole distorts gravity to
such a degree the light behind the black
hole can instead curve up and around the
Event Horizon giving us a view behind
the monster the black hole itself
appears larger than it really is again
due to the extreme warping of SpaceTime
lines of sight that would normally graze
past the edge of the Event Horizon
instead wrap around it from our
perspective the globe of the black hole
unfolds itself revealing every angle of
it in a single image producing what's
known as the
shadow that extreme gravity capable of
bending and distorting light like a
funhouse mirror reaches out to the
surroundings of the black hole stars
that Whip too close to the event horizon
risk their Doom if they pass within a
critical distance the gravitational
forces tear the star apart in a process
called a tidal disruption
event most of the gas however settles
into a distant orbit around the black
hole but 25,000 light years worth of gas
and dust sit between us and the center
of our galaxy that gas and dust scatters
and absorbs most wavelengths of light
preventing us from seeing the
Sagittarius a complex directly indeed if
we could it would be one of the
brightest objects in the
sky radio waves however pass through the
interstellar medium relatively
unaffected which is why we only saw the
first hints of trouble when we turned
our radio observatories towards that
constellation but despite the Fearsome
radiation pouring out of the gas
surrounding it the black hole itself was
relatively quiet it was nothing like the
distant quazar with their luminosities
Millions of Times Higher indeed except
for a faint smudge of radio emission
from outside our galaxy you wouldn't
even know that a super massive black
hole was
there but still the question was asked
could these be related could black holes
power the quazar if our galaxy hosted a
super massive black hole perhaps others
did
too as cosmologists began to understand
the Big Bang Theory more fully they
realized that structures in the universe
had to grow slowly long ago there were
only small differences in density across
the cosmos with hardly any variations
but over the course of hundreds of
millions of years those density
differences grew at large cosmological
scales the only force that really
matters is gravity a patch of matter
with a slightly higher density will
attract its neighbors pulling more
matter onto it that will give it an even
stronger gravitational pull which will
in turn pull even more matter towards it
and so on in a never- ended feedback
loop that drives small structures to
become big ones leading eventually to
the first Stars clusters and
galaxies all this gravitational action
leads to incredibly High densities in
the cores of these structures it's
simply where matter piles up the most
the cores of galaxies host many stars
and those stars are much more massive
than average they live short lives and
quickly die becoming black holes and
packed into such small volumes the black
holes quickly merge together their sizes
growing out of control becoming super
massive the idea that black holes could
power quazars was first proposed in 1964
just a year after the identification of
the first quazar itself but most
astronomers rejected the idea outright
after all at the time black holes were
considered a wild and probably
unphysical hypothesis Einstein's general
relativity was certainly a radical
reshaping of our understanding of
gravity but that didn't mean that every
corner of its mathematical structures
had to be replicated in the universe the
concept that matter could compress so
tightly that no other Force could
withand it was outlandish surely some
process would stop a dead star from
catastrophically collapsing into a point
of infinite
density but then astronomers came across
an intriguing system known today as
signus
X1 a bright source of X-ray radiation in
the constellation signus the
swan astronomers spent years trying to
understand how this star could produce
so many x-rays until observations later
in 1972 by astronomers Luise Webster
Paul murdin and Charles Thomas Bolton
revealed that it was not one star but
two the x-rays came not from the
invisible companion itself but from the
swirling plasma surrounding it detailed
observations of that plasma allowed
astronomers to calculate the mass and
more importantly the density of that
companion whatever it was it was more
compact than any known star and more
compact than any Star possibly could
be famed astrophysicist Steven Hawking
even bet against the possibility of
signus X1 containing a black hole saying
in his book A Brief History of Time that
when we made the bet in 1975 we were 80%
certain that signis X1 was a black hole
by now 1988 I would say that we are
about 95% certain but the BET has yet to
be
settled 10 years later he finally
conceded defeat signus X1 was the first
confirmed black
hole with black holes known to exist
everything clicked into place the
universe readily created Stellar Mass
black holes these black holes could
merge and consume material swelling them
to epic proportions and these Giants
would find themselves in the centers of
most if not all galaxies and so
observations confirmed that everywhere
we looked every Galaxy hosted a super
massive black hole we couldn't see them
they were and continued to be too far
away to allow us to monitor their
orbiting Stars directly and for all the
sophistication of of the Event Horizon
telescope besides our own Sagittarius A
star it has only managed to capture an
image of one other Galactic core but
astronomers could use the brightness of
the quazars themselves as a way to
measure the mass of their Central black
holes if super massive black holes did
power quazars then they could use
Doppler shifting to estimate the black
holes Mass but for this to work the
black holes had to somehow power the
quazars how could they do that if black
holes are purely gravitational how could
something that only pulls on the
surrounding matter produce such fearsome
[Music]
energies the red claxons blare and a
moment later you feel your ship
shuddering jolting uncontrollably the
stresses on the hull are almost too much
threatening their integrity together
with the the alerts flashing on your
display comes a new ominous warning
chime a flood of cosmic rays have struck
the ship microscopic particles slipping
through the molecular structures and
straight into the hearts of the crew but
you are determined to go on you push
your ship forward allowing it to slip
into the swirl of plasma in a
relativistic frenzy you don't even
bother trying to control it anymore as
the forces here are so strong so far
beyond known physics that there's no
choice but to give in to their Mercy the
ship is in uncontrolled
freefall a quick glance at a side
readout reveals what you already
suspected the external temperature is
reaching millions of degrees with the
internal life support systems beginning
to fail gripping the armrest you can do
nothing but watch as system after system
fails frustrated you swipe away the
warnings there's nothing new they can
tell you after yet another final Lurch
one strong enough to throw you against
your restraints to the point of bruising
comes a sudden
relief
silence you bring up the warnings
they're clear the temperature outside
has plummeted to nearly absolute zero
the cosmic rays have vanished the
radiation subsided your ship is still in
free fall but stabilized no longer
tumbling you activate the external
cameras shielding retracts revealing the
Optics sending their feed directly to
your display and there Dead Ahead you
see it or rather you don't the reason
you launched this mission to the center
of the Galaxy in the first place the
black
[Music]
hole the Deep Hearts within the cores of
galaxies are complicated busy places
like City centers there are far more
stars than average
compressed into uncomfortably small
volumes like City dwellers crammed into
tiny Apartments Street after Street
there are also far more aging red giants
located here a testament to the ability
of the cors of galaxies to produce
greater numbers of the most massive
stars but within all this brightness and
intensity is a dark side astronomers
estimate that the core of our own Galaxy
hosts tens of thousands of smaller black
holes a retinue in service to their m at
the center countless Supernova
detonations gravitational tidal
interactions and more tear Stars apart
their tattered remains scattered Among
the close-packed Stars nothing much
lasts long in the intensity of the core
and among all that chaos sits a thick
ring of cold dust a choking ring of smog
within the central city it is wide
around a thousand Li ear thick and the
dust slowly circles around the center
it's also a as thick as it is wide
forming a gigantic Taurus and is so cold
that the molecules and dust within it
are neutral if you were to travel
through it you would hardly notice it
due to its low density but that Dusty
Taurus obscures our view of most
Galactic cores as it efficiently absorbs
most of the radiation coming from within
only when we look from above or below do
we get a direct view of the
Maelstrom
while Karma nonviolent itself that ring
of dust signals an important transition
point in the galaxy outside the ring you
were in the galactic environment the
suburbs the physics dominated by all the
gravitational and electromagnetic forces
of the Galaxy at large but within the
ring only one thing
matters the super massive black hole it
is the central Landmark to guide all
lost Travelers
while even the largest ones take up less
than 1% of the total Galactic Mass they
are by far the most massive singular
objects within a galaxy far enough away
from them like our own solar system is
away from Sagittarius A star we don't
feel or even notice the black hole but
within the Taurus of dust the gravity of
the black hole takes over within this
region the black holes gravity dictates
the motion of every Star every clump of
gas and every
Speck of dust it's here that some Stars
stray dangerously close their orbital
motions bringing their speeds up to a
few per of the speed of light if they
get too close they're torn to shreds
their atoms joining the trains of gas on
their Dreadful March towards the Event
Horizon even closer to the black hole
that gas begins to lose control unable
to dictate its own motion it gets lost
in the crowded frenzy funneling to
incredible speeds driven by the the
extreme gravitational environment it is
this process that releases an incredible
amount of energy from the simple Act of
falling and to get an estimate of the
amount of energy released we look at
something called The Binding
energy to understand binding energy
imagine wanting to move a pile of stones
sitting at the bottom of a valley to
move the pile you must grab each
individual Stone and bring it to the top
of the ridge every time you do this you
just overcame the gravitational
potential energy of the stone you can
estimate how much energy you'll need for
the entire task by calculating the
potential energy of all the
stones now imagine pulling these stones
from the bottom of the valley and
sending them so far out into space that
they never come back now repeat that for
every single atom of the earth
effectively destroying the entire Earth
in the process the amount of energy you
would need to obliterate our planet is
called The Binding energy for a black
hole imagine dragging a particle from
The Event Horizon all the way out to a
distance of a few thousand light years
fighting against the gravity of the
black hole the entire time that is The
Binding energy of the particle around
the black hole which is equal to the
energy released when the particle Falls
from that distant orbit into the Event
Horizon and for a typical super massive
black hole that energy is roughly equal
to the rest mass energy of the matter
itself this process isn't perfect and
not all the energy available is released
as the particle Falls usually only about
10% of The Binding energy converts into
other forms that may not seem like a lot
but compare that efficiency to the 0.1%
of the rest mass energy released by
thermonuclear reactions in the hearts of
stars but this process doesn't lead to
an uncontrolled release of energy like a
bomb instead the release is slower and
in stages a steady buildup of excitement
as material continues to cram towards
the black hole as the gas heats up it
emits radiation normally radiation only
makes things warm but the intensity here
is so high that the radiation has a
pressure it is so intense that it can
push on things imagine the Summer Sun so
strong it literally could knock you
over the radiation pushes the gas
heating it up even more and sending it
away from the black hole but with the
gas pushed away it can't continue
accreting and so the radiation
dissipates but eventually the gas cools
down again allowing it to condense
towards the black hole and repeat the
accretion process this cycle of collapse
and inflation acts like the piston in a
car engine keeping the flow of gas in
check preventing it from suddenly
crashing into the black hole all at once
and keeping qu rars shining for millions
of
years yet that is just the beginning for
the gravity around super massive black
holes does not work
alone as any surrounding gas funnels
towards the black hole its orbital speed
increases by simple conservation of
angular momentum an ice skater can pull
their arms closer to their body to
increase their rotation speed and so can
material speed up as it whs closer to
the black hole but eventually its inward
movement is slowed the rotation
supported by cbal acceleration like a
planet locked in orbit around a star and
so soon enough the loose collection of
orbiting gas and dust compresses into a
tight thin disc of accretion around the
super massive black hole all that
infalling and compression heats the gas
to incredible temperatures the
gravitational potential energy
surrounding the black hole converted
into heat friction and radiation a
simple matter of too much material
cramming into too small of a
volume the disc glows primarily at
ultraviolet wavelength but also across a
broad range of the electromagnetic
spectrum in addition the disk constantly
streams out Showers of high energy
particles known as cosmic rays electrons
and protons accelerated to nearly the
speed of light those microscopic bullets
can occasionally strike a Wandering low
energy Photon at infrared or visible
wavelengths and when that happens the
particles transfer their energy to the
photons turning them into high energy
x-rays the intense heat of the disc
causes the cold atoms and molecules to
unbind themselves forming an
electrically charged plasma the same
state of matter as Lightning these
rapidly moving electric charges around
the black hole create a magnetic field
and very quickly it generates the
conditions needed to power a Dynamo a
seemingly infinite supply of energy that
can turn a small magnetic field into
something
devastating initially within the dis the
magnetic field lines follow the motion
of the gas swirling in Rapid circles
around the black hole but the innermost
regions of the dis rotate far faster
than the outer regions forcing the
magnetic field lines to coil up on
themselves storing up a tremendous
amount of energy
the motion of the gas within the disc
isn't smooth and steady instead it's
chaotic and turbulent like a running
River with portions of gas clumping and
colliding waving back and forth as they
swirl in The Firestorm when a clump of
this gas drifts away from the disc it
pulls on the magnetic field like a bit
of string but the difference in rotation
from one section of the disc to another
twists that Loop of the magnetic field
around itself the action of rotation
eventually stretches that magnetic field
back down into the disc this is a Dynamo
at work which turns chaotic turbulent
motions in the disc into an increasingly
strong magnetic field surrounding the
black hole normally magnetic fields
don't affect the Motions of matter
except in very small ways but as the
magnetic forces ratchet up within the
accretion disc surrounding the giant
black hole they begin to dominate The
Motions of material the closer the gas
gets to the black hole the more unstable
the orbits become and there is a certain
special distance known as the innermost
stable circular
orbit any gas that falls below that
orbit is
doomed most of the gas Falling Towards
the black hole ends its life at the
Event Horizon never to be seen again but
some gets caught in the twisting and
winding Paths of the magnetic field
lines their force is so strong that they
Channel and guide the gas as it falls
but how does this lead to the radar pin
Pricks we see in the distant sky that is
still a bit of a mystery one hypothesis
is called the Blandford szc process
named after the two physicists who came
up with the idea the key to this idea is
the fact that the black hole itself is
rotating when it does it drag SpaceTime
in the region around it like moving a
heavy coffee table twists the rug
beneath this region called the erosphere
forces any object entering into it to
rotate along with the black hole this
includes magnetic fields the strong
magnetic fields within the disc punch in
and out of the ergosphere which forces
them to twist up on themselves twisting
Fields create a tube of magnetic energy
stretching above and below the black
hole While most of the charged partic
Les following those magnetic field lines
end up plunging below the Event Horizon
some just barely scratch the surface
accelerated by the extreme magnetic
energies within the ergosphere following
the lead of the field lines the charged
particles race away from the black hole
in the form of long thin Jets of
radiation Lighthouse beams racing out
into the dark this radiation is
primarily composed of radio waves and it
is here that we finally find the or
of
quazar the particles in the Jets are
incredibly powerful accelerating to
nearly the speed of light they race out
of the galactic core and punch through
the Galaxy altoe stretching for up to
millions of light
years eventually however they lose steam
the particles interacting with the
intergalactic medium that surrounds
every Galaxy when they finally stop they
create a high pressure zone of charged
particles
these bubbles transfer heat all the way
from the innermost regions surrounding
the super massive black holes into the
volumes of entire clusters of galaxies
which can stretch for over a million
light years across that is how powerful
these systems are not only can they be
seen from across the cosmos but they can
raise the average temperature of entire
galaxy clusters the largest
gravitationally bound objects in the
universe
this picture involving super massive
black holes the Ring of dust surrounding
them the Ferocious secretion disc and
the magnetized outflows explains almost
every observation of active galaxies if
we see the central core of a galaxy face
on we see the intense radiation from the
accretion disc combined with the strong
radio emission from the Jet and we
recognize it as a quazer if we happen to
be looking directly down the barrel of
the jet then we get the most extreme
emission and we call it a
Blazer it's like Humanity first
encountering cats in astronomical
observations sometimes they see the
whiskers or a porw or a swishing tail
initially these seem like completely
different objects but over time we
realize that they're really just
different perspectives of the same kind
of
creature but what of other active
galaxies that aren't even loud in the
radio spectrum the solution here is that
not every Galactic core is
active to power a quazar the black hole
needs to feed without a supply of new
material the entire system shuts down no
gravitational collapse no accretion disc
no twisting magnetic fields no
relativistic Jets no
nothing this picture also explains why
we see no quazars in the nearby Universe
active Galactic nuclei can last for
incredibly long times the long longest
running quazars can run for over a
million years but they require constant
streams of new material to feed their
fires the early Universe was much
smaller than it is today with galaxies
much closer together and undergoing
frequent mergers with every merger new
material Finds Its way to the center of
the Galaxy setting off a feeding event a
new round of quazar activity but today
with the universe much older and far
larger Galaxy mergers do not happen
often with no new supplies of gas we see
no quazars in the local volume of the
cosmos indeed our own Galactic core is
quiet although Sagittarius A star hosts
Stars dust and gas around it it's a
relative the empty region compared to
the cause of
quazars but this was not always the
case in 2010 astronomers using the
firery gamma race Space Telescope
identified two gigantic regions
stretching above and below the galactic
plane each one over 50,000 Li years
across computer simulations revealed
what caused them a feeding event several
million years ago whether it was a
cluster of stars or a Wandering clump of
interstellar gas that met its end in the
hungry Moore of Sagittarius A star our
black hole destroyed it quickly
shredding it into an accretion disc
around found the Event
Horizon and then the same physics went
to work the accretion disc energized a
powerful magnetic field which created
Jets and launched relativistic particles
away from the Galaxy where they still
sit
[Music]
today indeed it seems that every galaxy
has gone through at least one active
phase spending some of its life cycles a
quazar with the central core of the
Galaxy barely a few light years across
out shining not just its own galaxies
but a thousand galaxies
combined but despite our growing
comprehension of the incredibly
energetic forces powering these vast
dynamos the quazar we see are still too
bright the super massive black holes
that serve as their gravitational power
sources are also very very
big too big and they are not the only
issues astronomers continue to discover
quazars appearing in the earlier and
earlier
Universe too
early quazar seem impossibly big and
impossibly bright existing impossibly
early in the history of the
cosmos what does this
[Music]
mean everything about quazars is the
very definition of
extreme the largest known super massive
black hole weighs over 66 billion solar
masses if you were to place that black
hole in our own solar system with its
Singularity at the center by the time
you reach the orbit of Pluto you would
be less than 1% of the way to its Event
Horizon we currently know of around 1
million active quazar and suspect that
there are at least 10 million more in
the observable Universe yet to be seen
each one pumping out more energy than a
thousand galaxies combined each one a
fierce engine of plasma and radiation
and quazars have been with the universe
almost since its birth the most distant
known quazar named J 0313
d186 was firing when our universe was
only 670 million years old that's just
5% of its present age but
astrophysicists aren't quite sure how
these black holes appeared so early and
got so big in the relatively Short age
of the
cosmos the only way that we know for
sure how to make black holes is through
the deaths of massive stars so by this
Logic the first black holes couldn't
exist until the first generation of
stars lived and died if those early
stars were like the stars of the modern
Universe then they left behind black
holes no more than a few times the mass
of the sun done from there the black
holes had to grow and they have two
options available merging and accreting
matter black holes especially massive
ones don't merge all that often at least
theoretically initially when two black
holes encounter one another interactions
with their environments allow them to
draw closer together but eventually all
that's left between them is their own
gravitational pole as the black holes
wind around each other they emit
gravitational waves which pulls energy
out of the system and allows the black
holes to sneak closer together once the
black holes within a few light years of
each other sufficient gravitational wave
emission alone would take longer than
the age of the universe and astronomers
still don't have a solution to this
obstruction calling it the final parek
problem yet despite this we do know they
merge
we have detected signature ripples in
SpaceTime from merg events with
gravitational wave detectors and when we
scan the cosmos for super massive black
holes we usually find only one residing
in each Galactic core despite each
Galaxy having suffered multiple merger
of vents so although the universe has
clearly solved the final Parc problem we
don't yet know how however even the most
optimistic estimates for Black Hole
production and merger rates can't
explain the largest and earliest quazars
so that leaves accretion to give black
holes their exceptional masses but once
again we run into a problem the same
seesing of radiation and gravitational
collapse that keeps quazar illuminated
for millions of years prevents large
amounts of gas from reaching the black
hole quickly this process is known as
the Edington limit and while not a hard
and fast rule of the universe it does
present a challenge if black hole are to
reach super massive status they need to
find a clever way around this and
somehow shove extra material through the
Event Horizon without heating it up to
the point that it escapes the vicinity
of the black
hole compounding this problem is the
lack of observational evidence for
so-called intermediate Mass black
holes these black holes should sit in a
mass range well above Stellar Mass black
holes which weigh only up to a few dozen
times the mass of the Sun and Below
super massive black holes which weigh
millions or billions of solar masses we
should see these in between Class black
holes everywhere representing an
intermediate stage of growth between the
Stellar mass and super massive black
holes but we don't on the other hand the
results from gravitational wave
detectors suggest that black holes
emerging far more often than we had
initially assumed in order to get the
detection rates that we observe many
small black holes had to have merged in
the history of the universe meaning that
they find each other close their orbits
and merge quite efficiently in addition
those same results suggest that there
are many more small black holes than we
had initially assumed based on simple
Stellar
deaths the result is a confusing Tangled
mess it is clear our understanding of
the growth and evolution of black holes
is missing something traditional models
of Galaxy and star formation don't seem
to be cutting it so perhaps it's time to
turn to more exotic
[Music]
models one possibility is that dark
matter itself can directly collapse to
form black holes dark matter is the
dominant form of matter in the universe
making up roughly 80% of the mass of
every single Galaxy but in the simplest
models of dark matter it doesn't
interact with itself and so has
difficulty clumping together at small
scales when it comes to something like a
Galaxy most theorists assume that the
dark matter is roughly evenly spread out
but in some more complicated models of
this mysterious form of matter it is
capable of small infrequent interactions
with itself this would cause it to Clump
together rapidly especially in the high
density days of the early universe and
if enough Dark Matter clumps into a
small enough volume quickly enough then
its own gravitational weight can take
over leading to catastrophic collapse
and the formation of a giant black hole
a black hole potentially big enough to
begin powering quazars before the first
Stars had even Arisen another
possibility is that our assumptions
about star formation don't apply in the
early Universe in today's Cosmos Stars
can only get so large this is because
the nebula that collapse to form them
can only grow to a certain size before
they begin to efficiently lose their
heat and collapse but that efficient
cooling depends on the presence of
heavier elements to radiate away the
energy of the nebula the early Universe
however lacked such heavier elements
because massive stars have to live and
die to enrich the interstellar medium so
perhaps Stars hundreds of times more
massive than the sun could have formed
when those giant Stars die they would
leave behind much larger black holes or
perhaps the ution is something even more
exotic maybe black holes have been with
us since the earliest moments of the Big
Bang in this scenario the Exotic
conditions and phase transitions of the
first few seconds in the history of the
universe spawned countless small black
holes known as primordial black holes
though many observations have ruled out
the existence of black holes like these
there is still the possibility of their
existence there may not be a lot of them
but if enough survived into the age of
Galaxy formation they could provide a
shortcut to quazar building bypassing
the usual rout of star and black hole
formation it's these questions and many
more that provided motivation to build
the James web Space Telescope which is
currently probing the first generations
of stars galaxies and quazars to appear
in the
universe regard less of these Mysteries
one thing has become clear galaxies and
their super massive black holes are
inextricably linked together and the
formation of quazars plays a key role in
that
relationship and in the early 2000s
astronomers made a startling realization
it's not just simply a matter of every
known Galaxy hosting a super massive
black hole at its Center but the
properties of that black hole are
closely linked to the properties of the
the host
Galaxy for example the greater the black
hole Mass the higher the temperature in
the galactic core and the higher the
Stell of velocity within and the larger
the black hole is the more massive the
overall Galaxy is and so it appears that
super massive black holes don't evolve
independently of their host galaxies and
turning on and off quazar activity plays
a key role in that self-regulating
connection if a Galaxy accretes a lot of
material either by gravitationally
attracting gas and its surroundings or
by cannibalizing another galaxy that
Galaxy now has a lot of new material to
boost star formation but a lot of that
material winds its way into the core
which turns into an accretion disc and
launches a jet turning the core of the
Galaxy into a
quazar all that radiation envelops the
black hole's host Galaxy heating the
entire contents of its interstellar
medium if the gas is too hot start can't
form efficiently this means that what
would have been a burst of sudden star
formation turns into a steady trickle
but this is good for the Galaxy too much
star formation at once would use up all
the available reservoirs of gas which
would ultimately end star formation too
soon but the quazar acts like a break
preventing too many stars from forming
in a short period of time it seems
almost every galaxy has gone through a
quazar phase and these galaxies continue
to regularly pump pump out to new stars
at a predictable efficient
rate this quazar back and forth explains
the relationship between galaxies and
their super massive black holes when the
Galaxy grows larger so does the black
hole and feedback from La quazar keeps
star formation in
check and this also applies to our own
galaxy The Milky Way way Grew From
countless merges and cannibalization of
smaller galaxies and each one of these
interactions could have flooded the
Galaxy with so much new material that
star formation became uncontrolled using
up all the available gas in just a few
hundred million years but Sagittarius A
star kept us in check preventing stars
from forming too quickly indeed it could
be that without Sagittarius AAR
activating as aaza deep in our distant
past then our our own son may never have
formed and we may never have been
here but this happy equilibrium will not
last long in 5 billion years our galaxy
will begin to merge with our nearest
neighbor the Andromeda galaxy our two
super massive black holes will find each
other and also merge material tattered
remnants of stars and nebuli destroyed
by the gravitational forces of the
merger will find its way into the new
core
and when it does the slumbering Giant in
the center will reawaken activating its
Mighty engines of gravity and magnetic
fields and pouring its tirelessly Fierce
radiation into the new Galaxy snuffing
out any hopes of peace and quiet for
ages to
come you've been watching the entire
history of the universe don't forget to
like And subscribe and leave us a
comment to tell us what you think thanks
for watching and we'll see you next
time